Не лише на Різдво чи Великдень - щонеділі
Спасо-Преображенський Собор УПЦ МП
заповнюється вірянами. Храм розміщений
на околиці Києва, в житловому масиві Теремки. Серед прихожан - родина Кравченків.
- Я була до одруження взагалі прихожанкою Київського патріархату,
хоча хрещена свого часу в Московському.
- А я завжди був прихожанином Московського патріархату.
Подружжя дуже сподівається на об’єднання Української православної церкви.
- Це велика радість, це велика благодать і це великий дарунок,
який нам дає Господь.
Що ми живемо саме в цей момент.
У тому ж храмі зустрічаємо вірянина Павла.
Він не такий оптимістичний.
- Наш Владика Онуфрій дав зрозуміти, що
не братиме в цьому участі. Можливо, частина наших архієреїв піде.
Але це тоді вони підуть в розкол знову.
Будемо тоді десь по хатах молитися.
Духовенство цього собору каже: настрої прихожан
щодо створення єдиної української помісної церкви їм невідомі.
На вибір не впливають, бо під час проповідей
жодного разу не згадували ні про томос,
ні про долю самого храму після автокефалії.
Про об’єднання церков говорять лише у приватних розмовах,
коли люди самі звертаються з запитаннями.
Останнім часом таке трапляється дедалі частіше.
- Такі питання стають, коли людина приходить до сповіді
або частіше просто так, у спілкуванні.
Звісно, що запитують, тому що це питання, яке стосується багатьох людей.
Віруючі хвилюються через це.
Як воно буде, що воно буде. Звісно, ми як священики
самі не знаємо, як воно достеменно буде,
якою буде конфігурація тої церкви.
Утім, поза храмом духовенство та настоятель
Спасо-Преображенського Собору
митрополит Олександр називає надання Україні томосу
логічним завершенням шляху, який пройшла
Українська православна церква за час незалежності України.
Така позиція серед духівництва УПЦ Московського патріархату -
радше виняток, адже йде в розріз із позицією керівництва церкви.
Хоча за часів покійного митрополита Володимира,
кажуть священики храму, було інакше.
- Блаженніший справді в першу чергу переслідував інтереси суспільства,
інтереси України. Україна йде до того, щоб отримати
свою церкву вчасно. От коли цей час настане -
це питання він залишав відкритим.
Але навіть тут представлено у вирізці газети,
що він про цей процес думав.
Він його не знімав з рахунку, він це чекав.
Частина прихожан цього собору, з якими поспілкувалася DW,
прислухаються до нинішнього патріарха Онуфрія.
Вони не до кінця розуміють, що таке томос,
і відмовляються вірити в канонічність
об’єднаної православної української церкви.
- Ще було б нічого, якщо б у нас була ця єдина церква,
помісна, чи яку там вони хочуть, але тільки щоб вони, вибачте, не лізли
до православної канонічної церкви. Але ми всі
чудово розуміємо, що так не буде.
Тобто якщо їм, не дай Бог, дадуть зараз владу,
зараз почнуться… ну, не гоніння, але відбирання храмів як мінімум.
А дехто просто  довіряє думці духовенства.
Андрій - прихожанин Московського патріархату.
У цій церкві похрестив обох своїх дітей.
Каже, якщо його духовний отець Віталій піде в об’єднану церкву, - піде за ним.
- Батюшка для мене є близьким другом.
Не як фізична особа, а близький друг, хто допомагає мені зв’язуватися і чути молитви,
якими я молюся до Бога. Я ходжу просто до Бога,
для мене не принципово.
Уже 15 грудня у Софії Київській відбудеться
об’єднавчий собор, на якому мають затвердити
статут нової церкви та обрати її предстоятеля.
Саме від єдності запрошених ієрархів УПЦ
Київського та Московського патріархатів
та Української автокефальної православної церкви
залежить не лише успіх створення помісної церкви,
але й мир серед вірян.